hey guys welcome back to bunk shaker
today I'll work on the layout of the
coaster as well as some terrain editing
because both are really some of the main
additions in alpha 2 and I haven't
really had time to play around with them
quite yet and I really like the way that
the new coaster creator is in alpha 2
point 2 and of course the terrain editor
from Alpha 2 is a really big and great
addition so I'll definitely be able to
get some good practice with that as well
but I'll also be doing a couple of like
more off topic stuff in the video that I
can stop myself from doing like some
small scenery objects like a small
prototype steam engine at the end of
this video and this quick bridge I
wanted to have for the EQ at the
entrance of the station I know it seems
quite awkward that this is where the
queue enters the station since it's not
exactly the front of the building but I
just wanted to have it over here to have
more space for the acute actually sort
of sweep through the area of the coaster
and leave the exit path just as a quick
path which also looks quite good from
the front but just quickly connects to
the part the rest of the park and what I
also really wanted to do here is to
build this quick bridge over here which
is I'll actually get into many bridges
throughout this coaster I think I'll get
like three or four bridges and that's
not even counting what the future lift
Hills can it'd be like basically because
for one they're just really fun to make
and it's just a really good practice of
getting all sorts of different little
bridge designs in with these sort of
industrial looks because it quite
honestly is also a really good way to
get some industrial looking scenery into
the landscape but it's also something I
want to get in here just to have a bit
more depth in the landscape itself make
it a bit more playful because I think
it's just a lot more interesting to have
bridges going on and different height
levels of paths and rollercoasters that
also to sort of dive underneath each
other and go over each other things like
that to just make the entire landscape a
bit more more interesting to look at in
that respects I also figured I could try
to get a quick cog in here
that didn't quite work so I put that
aside actually I might get back to it at
some point in future I do intend to have
a lot of gears and cogs and pipes at
some point in the future but what I
should say though and this is quite a
painful thing that makes me feel a bit
sad face because output 2.2 actually had
a bug fix and I am not entirely happy
with that bug fix it's basically fixed
the bug which I talked about in the last
video and sort of felt that that I
didn't show off how to do it
it was the bug that if you take an
object and rotate it using the three
axis gizmo and then select a war you can
actually get Wars in all sorts of
rotations which they're not meant for so
you could get diagonal Wars and angled
walls and stuff like that but that was
obviously not the intention so they
actually took that bug out of alpha 2.2
but that was pretty much the bug that I
was intending to use and pretty much
relied on for this entire idea of a
steampunk coaster because it would allow
me to get pipes in all sorts of
directions and now that that bug isn't
here anymore it'll be a bit harder to
get like all of those different pipes
and cogs into different sections of the
coaster but I do still want to keep
going with this thing and see what can
still well be made out of this anyway
because there is one little and very
nice thing that is still sort of buggy
about an entire bug fix which is that if
you already have a building which uses
that bug to get an object in a rotation
which is not supposed to be in you can
actually just copy that building over
and duplicate it and have it the same
copy with the same rotation which was
supposed to be fixed and I hope they're
not going to fix that because I'm gonna
have to rely on that to actually copy
over the few horizontal pipes that I
laid down in the last episode into also
two pipes that I want to make in the
future so I definitely want to get into
some of that real industrial scenery
around the rollercoaster but in this
episode I'll focus just on the layouts
of the coaster or mostly on the layout
of the coaster and the terrain around it
because this is going to be very much a
terrain conforming coaster it's quite
inspired by the vakama mind train
coasters especially the
two versions like big grizzly Runaway
Mine Train or Expedition Everest things
like that although on a much smaller
scale I would say much more on a scale
of the Seven Dwarfs Mine Train for
instance in listening them if it's not
Disney Magic Kingdom high actually
completely forgotten which park it's
located in but yeah that's the sort of
idea that I'm going for it's going to be
quite a family ride so you can see it's
not that tall it's not going to have any
inversions or anything like that it's
just gonna have those typical four coma
sort of swoops around
well the terrain and some scenery and
just be quite a relaxed ride in general
and it's gonna focus mostly on scenery
though that said I do think the the way
that the coaster layout is built is
quite important for this especially
given how prominent the coaster is in
this case since it is quite a compact
coaster and it interacts along with the
terrain and the paths so one sort of
thing that I also really wanted to make
sure with this coaster was that the
layouts not only rides well I guess but
also looks good and could work well with
the scenery around it and so it's gonna
be quite compact it's have a lot of
helixes and as you can already see a lot
of parts where it goes underneath itself
or underneath paths or over paths stuff
like that it's quite dense in terms of
not just how compact the layout is but
also how much it interacts with the
surroundings I also wanted to give it
that very dark sort of metallic ish red
colour I'm not entirely sure if there is
a specific name for this shade of red
there probably is but I don't know
exactly what it would be but yeah I
think it is a good way to get a sort of
steampunk vibe to the coaster and also
get some shades of red into this area
because at the moment there is no way to
recolor any scenery pieces many of the
scenery pieces are very blue white
brownish and there's no real shades of
red in there at all so I kind of wanted
to get that in the coaster or the
general scenery with the coaster tracks
and also the paths as you can see and as
for the choice of the coaster track and
terrain that is this kind of
something that makes no sense it's
intended to be a vakama mind train like
coaster
not exactly a PNM or Java no Lautrec and
I just figured a Java NOLA hyper would
work quite well because it kind of has
like the large family cosa trains to it
and it looks a little bit steampunk ish
as well I feel at least more steampunk
e'en than any of the other cosa trains
do so that's why I figured a hyper
coaster would be most fitting but this
is definitely not a hyper coaster in the
way that it's laid out and kind of wish
we would have some vakama things at
least I'm still crossing my fingers for
some point in the future anyway in this
last section of the coaster I wanted to
like let it dip into a small valley and
actually go underneath the paths which
is also done for just a couple of
reasons I it's just a really nice way to
get the path to go over the
rollercoaster which I figured would just
be really cool over there and also a
nice way to remain like the coaster to
have some speed throughout the layouts
as you can probably see right now it
makes the layout pretty fine which I was
pretty flat about given that I didn't
test it before up to this point but it's
like a way to get the coaster to not
really lose any speed since like the
higher parts never really go down that
much and the last part really goes down
a lot lower than the station so it just
kind of remains quick throughout the
entire ride and then just before this
station it goes up quite a lot and
should go into the brakes quite smoothly
which is a good way to keep it going for
quite a long time while still not making
it too intense since it is a family
coaster after all and yeah this will
just be like one quick little dip into
the valley and then it's gonna run into
the brake run where I won't have any
transfer tracks or anything like that
though because there is no entirely any
space left for it which is kind of
awkward I might want to look at it at
some point in the future but yeah this
is the finished layout of the coaster at
the moment though I should definitely
note even though this is going to be
more or less the final layouts after
some smoothie smooth it's definitely not
going to be the final look of the
coaster and the terraforming is also not
going to be the final look of but the
scenery around the coaster is going to
look like in terms of it being built
around the mountain and kind of in a
very small Canyon as well since I do
want to use a lot of rock work still to
move toward the coaster which I do
realize it's not going to be as easy as
just filling it up with some
terraforming which is also kind of
strange because it's been newly added to
the game and I might as well make use of
the terrain editing but I actually
rather want to make use of the rocks
instead because you can just get them to
be closer to the track and I really want
it to be very terrain conforming that it
follows the rocks all the time but I do
want to mix the sort of scenery rocks
with the terraforming just to get some
slightly different textures and slightly
different sort of surfaces in here and
not have everything looked like exactly
the same Rock but yeah I will add a lot
of scenery onto this mountain so this is
definitely not going to be the final
look of the terraforming or the scenery
or the way in which the coaster is gonna
look in general this is just sort of the
very naked layouts at the moment and the
queue I kind of want the queue to just
sweep along this area and have some like
scenery interaction and interaction with
the coaster over there and I'm not
entirely sure if I actually want to have
like a real zigzag pattern underneath
the building of anything like that at
any point in the queue line it's already
pretty lengthy at that point and I think
it should be more or less fine this way
I'll still have to look into that
in the future though I'm not entirely
sure what I'm gonna do with that corner
of this map now for the lips hill since
it's a really prominent feature of this
coaster and also the one that you kind
of see most from all sort of angles that
you can look at the coaster from
especially from the past I really wanted
to make the lift Hill sort of part of
the scenery as for instance Baron 1898
this as well and actually give it a bit
of a like industrial sort of lift Hill
with not the in-game supports but some
metallic sort of hybrid wooden supports
with
winnin catwalks as well just to make it
look a little bit more interesting and
unique and set it apart from the rest of
the track of the coaster and I might do
some other stuff with it in the future
as well like put a small roof on the top
of the lift Hill and things like that I
do have some plans to put like a tower
on top of this little mountain and make
like a proper wienie for the top of this
lift cell but I'm not entirely sure when
I'm actually gonna go into that and at
the moment I just wanted to play it safe
for an episode and just get into the
details that I knew for sure how I
wanted to get them and how they would
work out in the end I also wanted to
have this little sort of quick little
protection alongside this part of the
coast room not just because I obviously
needed to fence that off because
otherwise the track is used way too
close to the path and people could just
climb onto the track and you don't
really want people to do that and I do
have some safety measures and also just
kind of looks cool to have that sort of
overhang which sticks out of the
mountain and lets the coaster sort of
semi get into a little cave before it
dips out again and does that little
helix and I also wanted to do a bit of
Tarot painting over here I'm not going
to get into too complex of Turin
painting but I just wanted to get a bit
of a darker texture get some darker
grass and definitely get some of that
dark rock sort of text you I do find
that the textures in the moment at the
moment even though they're very limited
they work really well if you mix them so
I can really recommend setting the
intensity very low and you sort of
spraying some rockwork onto grass to
create like some slightly darker grass
which actually works quite well
especially with this sort of industrial
gritty theme or makes the grass with
sand with like a very slight intensity
on the sand just get some slightly
lighter brass or yeah you can kind of
mix them in all sorts of ways if you
keep the intensity quite low which is
quite a fun thing to play around and
actually gives you some very different
looking textures from just what the game
very strictly gives you
now over here I wanted to have this
quick little bridge over this part where
the coaster dives underneath the path
there's a little helix and dives back
into the path or underneath the path I
should say which is quite inspired
actually my big Risley ronamayk Runaway
Mine Train in Hong Kong if you don't
know about that coaster it's a really
cool mind train coaster made by the coma
and it's actually a minor in coaster
which has a bike backwards actually as
well and it just has like an amazing
sort of way in which it follows the
terrain and interacts with the path and
the scenery and that's in that way it's
sort of an inspiration here even though
the theme is completely different and
the layout is - it's sort of that's real
interactive aspect that I want to get in
here as well I also really want to make
this coaster look charming in a way
which is a really strange sort of goal
to have for a coaster but I don't
exactly want to make something really
impressive or large or epic or anything
like this it's just a sort of small
experiment to make something that's like
small and charming and unique which I
find it's actually the hardest sort of
thing to do not just because what is
charming and what isn't is sort of
subjective and more or less based on my
own judgment here it's your stats making
something really large and impressive
and epic it's just it's still something
you can kind of follow some rules or
guides for but there is no sort of guide
on how to make something look charming
it's just there is no real approach to
it it's really hard to really get that
across and that's what I really am
trying to do with this coaster to make
something that really has its own sort
of signature style and instead of being
like this very large Grande coaster it's
just a small family coaster with some
simple scenery or a simple maybe I do
mix a lot of elements in here but like
nothing that's completely very vast or
massive and yeah make that look just in
a way like a charming little family
coaster that's basically the objective
and in that way I feel like this is much
harder to do then make
and it sort of very large spectacular
ride just because it there is no way to
really get it done right except for what
you sort of feel should be done and what
you sort of feel is right and really
have to kind of follow well your
instincts with that I guess anyway
that's just a little bit of stuff which
I wanted to talk about but I have no
idea what you're actually gonna do with
that information I also wanted to make a
quick steam engine over here which is
not so much like a serious sort of
scenery projects over here but just
something that I quickly wanted to test
as a little prototype to mess around
with the pipes a bit more and try to
make that wheel of the steam engine
especially actually work somehow and of
course also sort of well put the main
theme of this coaster because it is
steampunk and every it revolves around
steam engine technology more or less in
the center sort of focal points of this
entire landscape and it's definitely
gonna be visible from many different
areas so yeah I just wanted to
accentuate this theme and this area with
a little steampunk engine or steam
engine I should say perhaps a bit in a
steampunk ish style it's also something
that I figured would work quite well
since I wanted to have some sort of
scenery piece over here but obviously
since this is right in front of the lift
so I didn't want to make anything that's
very tall
or I would more or less break the
perspective that I have over here so I
just wanted to have something that's
very small
and low but could still work quite well
as a sort of center point scenery piece
here and I think it works quite well to
have this little steampunk machinery
over here in the middle of it and
actually picked up quite a few ideas
that I still have to do on how you can
make some cogs and gears because there
definitely are many ways to get around
that with the current pieces and I might
actually make some pipes out of that
like little wooden piece which I think
should be quite feasible and actually a
good way to get some brass pipes so that
I think that's something I want to mess
around with in the next episode
that's way too early in the video to
talk about that I am running out of the
time apps though but I do still have
some small real-time parts that I do
want to show off a bit to at least show
what the layout looks like in its full
glory at the moment so this is what it
looks like it's not that tall as you can
see it is pretty small but it still goes
on for quite a while and has like really
that sort of higher section a middle
section and the lower section where it
dives underneath the path and this is
what it looked like looks like from the
path area in general with the steam
engine in front of it but there is still
a lot to add like at the moment it looks
quite empty and I really want to add
machinery and rocks and all sorts of
stuff all around the track and not leave
it as bare as it is at the moment and
for a final overview of what it looks
like this is it so thank you guys for
watching and I hope to see you guys in
the next episode